[Música]
el síndrome de dawn siempre ha estado
entre nosotros los humanos y tiene
efectos variables en los estilos de
aprendizaje también las características
físicas de la salud el acceso adecuado a
la salud a los programas de intervención
temprana y también la enseñanza
inclusiva así como la investigación
adecuada son vitales para todo el
crecimiento y el desarrollo de una
persona es que el síndrome de dawn es
una alteración genética causada por la
existencia de material genético extra en
el cromosoma 21 que se traduce en a
discapacidad intelectual una incidencia
estimada del síndrome de dawn a nivel
mundial se sitúa entre 1 de cada 1000 y
también una de cada 1.100 recién nacidos
las personas con síndrome de down no
suelen presentar más problemas de salud
en general sin embargo los avances
sociales y médicos han conseguido
mejorar toda la calidad de vida de todas
las personas con síndrome de dawn a
principios del siglo 20 también se
esperaba que los afectados vivieran
menos de 10 años ahora cerca del 80% de
los adultos que lo padecen superan la de
los 50 años para eso entonces quiere
salir para nuestra segunda invitada del
día ella es jimena gonzález fue
observadora del amo de las pasadas
elecciones en colombia las elecciones
legislativas también ha trabajado en
organizaciones como asodown y profamilia
además activista por los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos de equidad de
género de las personas con síndrome de
dawn pues jimena gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
es un gusto para nosotros que estés con
en nuestro programa hoy digamos este año
en el 2022 el lema es la palabra
inclusión que tanto ha mejorado o
empeorado la inclusión de ustedes las
personas con síndrome de down en
nuestras sociedades
hola muy buenos días a todos gracias por
esta invitación
pues la verdad
tenemos que ser incluidos en varios
programas
tanto por hablar de educación sexual y
reproductiva
tenemos que ser incluidos en nuestra
educación
en colegios
regulares
y pues en todo tipo de nuestras
habilidades que somos capaces
de estar en diversos campos
jimena le quiero preguntar si ustedes
han tenido o siguen tenían un tipo de
estigma cuéntenos también de su
experiencia usted tengo entendido
también que se acaba de grabar del
colegio está esperando ya para entrar a
la universidad usted estudió en algún
tipo de colegio especial es un colegio
digamos hoy corriente
en todos los colegios fueron regulares
todos me aceptaron por mi condición de
discapacidad intelectual síndrome de
dawn y pues
estoy muy orgullosa de mi condición de
discapacidad intelectual qué tipo de
iniciativas se realizan actualmente para
que sean más incluidos y digamos también
cuál fue su experiencia en el colegio
con sus compañeros con sus profesores
pues a mí que todos me dio en apoyando
yo iba
creciendo y va teniendo haces que
prácticamente un poquito tuve la
oportunidad de estar en cosas muy buenas
a partir de mi colegio
ahora jimena también usted es una
activista por los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de las personas con esta
condición con síndrome de down cuéntanos
entonces de qué se trata esta labor a
que apuntan ustedes
pues yo la verdad he hablado de telefe
sexuales y derechos reproductivos
y pues lo únicamente en ese tema he
hablado también en familia en el tema
del tema de la familia la inclusión
social en la educación para nosotros que
es un poco de un poco compleja ya que
nosotros estamos a muy distintos niveles
de aprender pero no somos capaces de ser
entendidos
ahora le pregunto a jimena que podrían
mejorar digamos nuestros gobiernos las
leyes que están actualmente para que
ustedes sean más comprendidos sean más
integrados en nuestras sociedades
ustedes a lo mejor digamos en el caso
colombiano han hablado con alguna
institución gubernamental para demandar
esto que ustedes se exigen
pues como ya lo sabemos todos nosotros
tenemos muchas facultades para poder
hacerlo somos capaces de llevar una vida
muy buena muy
que nos tienen tenemos
obviamente un poquito de apoyo por
nuestras familias por nuestras
organizaciones
que somos
personas
muy inteligentes para llevar una vida
plena y pues en la que queremos no la
que podemos elegir jimena hace poco en
colombia pasaron las elecciones
legislativas usted también fue una está
sabedoras de todo este proceso electoral
tienen algún tipo de representación
política ahora en el congreso digamos en
el caso específico de colombia o en otra
instancia gubernamental y que se
necesita si no la tienen para llegar a
eso
pues todos sabemos que menos que
nosotros por tener una condición de
discapacidad intelectual como es el
síndrome de down
y complejo
que después
bueno nosotros tenemos la mayor facultad
de entender las cosas no también tenemos
a elegir nuestra vida política
para cada uno ha hecho yo vi observadora
electoral y pues
tenemos la
como es una diligencia en nosotros la
verdad ya muy rápidamente para finalizar
gimeno usted quiere estudiar
comunicación social porque quiere
hacerlo
porque quiero seguir con estos temas muy
buenos porque la verdad me han permitido
y me han permitido sacar mi vida
adelante
qué
quiero seguir con derechos sexuales y
reproductivos
seguir hablando de cada uno de estos
temas porque no es el único tema que
utilizo para hablar sino que también
hablo de familias
hablo de cuidar el género hablo en
educación
para nosotros y la inclusión es
importante para todos nosotros no
únicamente